HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER --
WILL THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
HERE.
HERE HIGHLY [inaudible]
KALRA.
CALLER HERE THE PARTY.
STEINORTH.
THURMOND HERE REQUIREMENTS WE'RE
WEBER HERE FOREVER.
WE OF COURSE.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
WHERE CAN OKAY --
ó WITH THAT WE DO WE DO HAVE A
CORPSMAN --
THANK YOU COR HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO
AUTHORS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO THIS AFTERNOON'S
HEARING WILLIAM ONE BILL UP
BEFORE US TODAY --
WHICH IS AC ARE TWO SIX EIGHT
MISTER THURMAN --
IS HERE TODAY BUT I BELIEVE THE
AYE HIS CO AUTHORS GOING TO
PRESENT THE BILL MISS OUR QUIRK
SILVA.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY
[inaudible]
HERS.
AFTER THE JOINT AUTHORED A
REASON HE ARE. 68% BALANCE
[inaudible]
EDUCATIONAL TECH YES BROWN
HIGHEST PRIORITY. FOR CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION [inaudible]
NOW IT [inaudible] THIRTY YEARS --
THE WONDERFUL RESULTS THAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
YEA BUT ALSO.
SOME OF OUR SCHOOLS [inaudible]
VERY LARGE THERE THERE HAS BEEN
A RAPIDLY EVOLVING [inaudible]
HE RESULTING. FOR A REPAIR
EDUCATORS OFFERING STRONG.
CLEARLY POINTS STATE ABOUT THE
CURRICULA [inaudible]
DELIVERY.
PARADE PASSED THE MOTION OUT ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT [inaudible]
AS AND IF YOU [inaudible]
MY AMERICA.
WITH TECHNO [inaudible]
WE THERE NEEDS TO BE OF COURSE
TRAIN ALSO.
THAT ACCEPTANCE AND ABSOLUTELY.
PART OF THE CURRICULUM.
WE MIGHT AS BE ABLE. TO HAVE
LETTERS AND OTHER.
YOU PROBABLY PLEDGE THAT IF YOU
WANT TO SAY NEW AGE.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT EDUCATORS
AND MANY. FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT NECESSARILY
NECESSARY KEVIN [inaudible]
OR IT [inaudible]
AND WORKING OLOGY IT AGAIN YES
ATTY. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
PROGRAM FOR WE DON'T EVEN
REALIZE [inaudible]
CHARTER.
WATER ARE HERE [inaudible]
AS GLORIA [inaudible]
CHARTER [inaudible]
THAT.
IMPLEMENT TECHNOLOGY WE YOUR
HEAD WERE WE'RE ALL THE PARTS
THAT.
STUDENTS ARE TREATED
[inaudible]
OUT A BATTERY AND FORGET
MAYBE LOSE [inaudible]
OTHER INFORMATION [inaudible]
ATTY.
A WEB WELL.
SURE IT IS AVAILABLE IN THE
CHOOSE THEMSELVES [inaudible]
WORK AS TECHNOLOGY IS MOVING
VERY PROUD.
SO WITH THAT WE DO HAVE.
HERE TO TESTIFY JOHN TRAVELER
WHO IS AN EDUCATE [inaudible]
JOHN [inaudible]
HOPE RELIABLE.
THANK YOU PUT THIS IS PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY PLEASE TO TWO MINUTES
[inaudible]
AND
SO [inaudible]
SPECIAL [inaudible]
JUST [inaudible] FOR REYES.
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
PROGRAMS REGIONAL SUPPORT
SERVICES.
WAIT A HALF BURIED NOW
[inaudible]
PROGRAM [inaudible]
COLLEGE APPLICATIONS SURE
[inaudible]
BORN PROJECT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THE SERVICE.
MANAGER.
RIGHT ON THE WAY [inaudible]
YEAH.
AFTER A FEW [inaudible]
MR.
PEOPLE HAVE NO PLACE TO GO
[inaudible]
NOT ONLY [inaudible]
THE STORY.
THERE IS A YOU CAN BOB.
EXCESS ITEM WE KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT'S DONNA LOT TO MAKE.
AND TWO MINUTES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BUT THERE STILL IS THIS
HUGE ISSUE WITH STAFF
DEVELOPMENT --
OFTEN SOME PEOPLE WILL SAVE A
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
WELL.
AND NOT AND IF YOU COULD
SUMMARIZE [inaudible]
NO ALZHEIMER'S.
OKAY IN SUMMARY --
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA AL CAPP AND WILL CFF
WELL THERE'S A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY THERE'S A LOT OF
PRESSURE TO PUT ALL OF THAT INTO.
THE OTHER THING SALARIES
FACILITIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT
AND SO.
IT'S HARD TO PROVIDE EQUITY IN
TERMS OF THE NEED FOR THE STAFF
DEVELOPMENT SOME DISTRICT CAN
AFFORD TO DO THAT OTHERS CAN'T
SO WE'RE FINDING THROUGH ALL OF
OUR SURVEYS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THANK YOU IT IS AN ISSUE.
SO THANK YOU YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JOHN CRYPTO
I'M A FORMER --
CLASSROOM TEACHER IN GRADES FOUR
EIGHT AND NINE TWELVE OF BEEN
THE MADERA COUNTY TEACHER OF THE
YEAR IN THE PAST.
I'VE BEEN FORTUNATE TO START A
ONE TO ONE HIGH SCHOOL WHERE ALL
THE KIDS GOT A MACBOOK AND THERE
WERE A GOOGLE DOCS AND HIDE IT
IN A PROJECT BASED LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FROM DAY.
ONE AND TO JUST PUT IT
SUCCINCTLY A THE BEST
EDUCATIONAL RESEARCH SAYS THAT
TEACHERS DON'T GET BETTER.
UNLESS THEY HAVE FORTY HOURS OF
SUSTAINED PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PER YEAR.
AND THE FISCAL REALITY IS THAT
MOST DISTRICTS IF YOU CALL ANY
OF YOUR LOCAL DISTRICTS THEY
USUALLY PROVIDE ONE TO THREE
DAYS OF TRAINING.
PER TEACHER FOR YEAR AND THAT
AMOUNTS TO ABOUT EIGHTEEN HOURS
SO MOST DISTRICTS ARE ABOUT 50%
OF WHAT'S NEEDED TO TRULY
INCREASE EDUCATOR EFFECTIVENESS.
AND OUT ONE THING RIGHT NOW
THAT'S GONNA CLASSROOMS IS THAT
EVERYTHING IS IN FLUX.
OF YOU'VE HEARD OF PBI ES THE
WAY THAT WE INTERACT WITH
CHILDREN THE WAY THEY ARE
DISCIPLINE SYSTEM WORKS A
DIFFERENT.
CURRICULUM IS DIFFERENT ADDING
DEVICES DIFFERENT TESTING IS
DIFFERENT EVERYTHING'S INFLUX SO
I WOULD JUST LEAVE YOU WITH ONE
BIG IDEA.
WE NEED A KIND OF A STATEWIDE
PLAN OR OUTLINE OF WHAT BEST
PRACTICES ARE FOR THAT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT WHILE
WHEN THIS TRANSITION --
BECAUSE THE KIDS THAT ARE A
CLASS RIGHT NOW ARE GONNA BE ARE
CITIZENS OF THE FUTURE.
IF WE DON'T PREPARE THEM WHILE.
WE WILL NOT HAVE THE WORK FORCE
WE NEED.
WILL FAIL.
SECOND THANK IS REMOVED AND
SECOND ANY --
CONSUMMATED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SICK OF MISTER THEM.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE --
FOR HEARING THIS MATTER --
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF I
RECKON [inaudible]
TODAY -- I
WANNA FIRST THINK MY JOINT
AUTHORS I REMEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
OF FOR PRESENTING THIS AND FOR
SUPPORTING THIS ITEM NUMBER ONE
SEVEN CONVERSATION WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCE AS A TEACHER --
WITH STUDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO SOME OF THE MOST BASIC
KINDS OF TECHNOLOGY SUPPORT JUST
BASIC STUFF LIKE HAVING A
COMPUTER AND NOT.
HAVING THEM YOU KNOW MOUSE OR
SOMETHING TO TO YOU KNOW MAKE
SURE THAT WHAT WAS IN FRONT OF
THEM WAS ACTUALLY USEFUL --
IN ITS STRIKES ME THAT WE HAVE
SO MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE
THAT IS THE CASE THAT OUR STATE.
AND THAT THE THAT THIS MEASURE
SAYS LET'S MAKE THIS A HIGH
PRIORITY I THINK IS REALLY
CRITICAL AND I APPRECIATE.
OF THE OF THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS WELL AS THE
SPONSORS AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ALSO MENTIONED --
THAT THIS GROWS OUT OF CONCERN
OF FROM ONE OF OUR PARTNERS AT
THE COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
IN NAPA COUNTY.
ADOPT APARTMENT CHO WHO'S MADE
DISA UMPIRE FOR LIFELONG WORK
AND SO ON BEHALF OF OUR KIDS AND
EDUCATORS AND OTHERS TO GET THE
RIGHT TRAINING AND ACCESS TO
TECHNOLOGY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE
FOR AG ARE I THINK YOU ARE JUST
AS ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL I
DO NOT SEE ANY OPPOSITION.
A WITHOUT SEEING NO COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU
MAY CLOSE.
AND THAT WE WOULD JUST ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I THINK WHEN
WE MAKE SURE OUR STANDARDS ARE
CLEAR ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA REGARDING TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE.
TO GET PEOPLE ON THE SAME PAGE
SO TO SPEAK.
GREAT THANK YOU --
WITH THAT --
THE MOTION IS --
AS ADOPTED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THAT'D BE DOUBTED A TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY
[inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL ITSELF FIVE VOTES THANK
YOU MEMBERS THERE'S ANY MEMBERS
THAT ARE NOT HERE I WILL WAIT
AROUND FOR ABOUT TWO MINUTES AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA.
BECAUSE THE ROLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAU PLAYING FIELD.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE.
RIGHT NOW I NEED TO TAKE YOUR
YEAH AND PERHAPS IT WAS
[inaudible]
GOOD.
YOU'RE STILL WITH US
[inaudible]
WILL SUPPLY [inaudible]
NMHA IS.
NO BRING ON CLEAR.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED